to many people functional training and
bodybuilding are antithetical the two
lie at completely opposite ends of the
functional spectrum
functional training of course is all
about training to get better at things
that could mean getting better for your
sport or it could mean training to avoid
injury and improve energy for everyday
tasks
bodybuilding conversely is about looking
better big biceps therefore come at the
expense of good mobility giant legs are
more important than having enough cardio
to get up the stairs and for all these
reasons many people believe that they
are faced with a choice aesthetics or
performance either look good or move
good
this choice however is an illusion
firstly bodybuilding is far more
functional than many people give it
credit for the notion that bodybuilders
have fake muscle or anything like it is
nonsense and usually just an excuse used
by those people who secretly wished they
looked a little bit bigger
bodybuilders tend to use sub-maximal
loads with higher rep ranges so if a
bodybuilder is capable of benching 150
kilograms they might use a hundred
kilograms for eight reps this is
suboptimal for strength gains and it
leads to muscle that is somewhat less
dense and more puffy hence accusations
of fake muscle
the science behind this has something to
do with myofibrillar versus sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy this is a somewhat
controversial debate full of bro science
but the long and short of it is that
training with max weights leads to
thicker muscle fibers this is the
process of breaking down muscle fiber
and building it back up conversely
bodybuilding likely increases fluid
retention in the muscle cells and
increases glycogen stores
to reiterate there's no evidence of
sarcoplasmic or myofibrillar hypertrophy
as distinct entities it's far more
likely that both these forms of
hypertrophy occur simultaneously in all
cases alongside countless other
mechanisms
but it's also true anecdotally that
bodybuilders do have puffier muscles
lower strength and also greater strength
endurance but that strength endurance is
the point i want to focus on this is
attributable to those increased glycogen
stores which draw more fluid into the
muscle coincidentally
there's no such thing as a
non-functional muscle and there's no
such thing as a non-functional
adaptation evolution doesn't care about
18 inch biceps for their own sake having
puffy muscles then must serve some
purpose
and that purpose is muscle endurance
allowing you to exert strength over a
long period
this makes perfect sense as it adheres
to the said principle specific
adaptations to impose demands
bodybuilders train with sub-maximal
weights for much higher repetitions
therefore they are able to exert
strength for longer than powerlifters
who practice calling upon their strength
for one huge effort
as i have stated time and time again
strength endurance is more useful more
often than max strength when was the
last time outside of the gym that you
had to lift something so heavy you could
only manage one repetition
remember even strength endurance
is specific you increase the number of
mitochondria in specific muscles you
improve your efficiency controlling
specific muscle groups and motor
patterns so if you want to get better at
holding a position for an extended
period of time
the best thing you can do is hold that
position under resistance for a
significant period of time
bodybuilding style pump training
therefore builds real usable strength
and there are countless more benefits to
getting a pump too because this kind of
training causes blood and oxygen to pool
in the muscle it also encourages other
positive changes this is a great way to
increase localized growth hormone and
other metabolites it also helps to
increase vascularization permanently
increasing blood supply to boost healing
and energy and don't be mistaken
bodybuilders still build max strength
too i often read statements like
bodybuilders have large but seemingly
weak muscles this is a gross
misrepresentation sure bodybuilders
aren't as strong as powerlifters but
they're still extremely strong just take
a look at someone like franco columbu
who for a long time was considered the
strongest man on the planet and
bodybuilders don't only use isolation
training just fyi pretty much any
bodybuilder worth their salt will still
bench press squat and deadlift
that is the other criticism of
bodybuilding that it involves a lot of
isolation training however that means
focusing on just one muscle group and
often this is done sitting down or the
assistance of a machine the result of
isolation training is that you don't
learn to move the muscle in tandem with
other muscles this not only prevents you
from strengthening the stabilizers that
would realistically be called into
action in a real world setting but it
also prevents you from learning useful
movement patterns consider a preacher
curl sitting down with your upper arm in
a fixed position hinging at the elbow
the bicep curl can be a useful movement
we use something similar when climbing
carrying children or shopping getting
someone in a headlock throwing a hook
but to do any of these things we also
need to stiffen the core and generate
power from the feet up
this may sound damning but keep in mind
that isolation training isn't a bad
thing in itself
isolation training can be a useful way
to target weaker muscles to avoid injury
when training to failure and more this
is only an issue if isolation training
is the only foundation of your training
combine it with compound moves and it
serves as accessory work
keep in mind that nearly every sport
nearly every form of strength training
will have some glaring emissions when it
comes to muscle development power
lifters famously don't move much in the
transverse plane calisthenics athletes
often struggle to build their legs
equally to the upper bodies yogis don't
practice much in the way of pulling
movements variety and balance is key to
effective functional training and to me
that means incorporating multiple
different modalities of training and in
fact the focus on creating a balanced
and symmetrical physique in bodybuilding
can be a huge asset bodybuilders are far
more likely to spend time bringing up
lagging muscle groups fixing asymmetry
in their calves or focusing on some
external rotation to develop those rear
delts
for all these reasons bodybuilding is
surprisingly functional in fact when you
watch those strength competitions on
youtube or bodybuilder versus freerunner
the bodybuilder almost always exceeds
expectations i've seen massive
bodybuilders land backflips on their
first attempt
just as bodybuilding is surprisingly
functional so too is functional training
surprisingly aesthetic
just like bodybuilders functional
athletes spend a lot of time developing
their strength endurance
only they tend to do this in a more full
body manner
precisely because this is useful in a
match game or fight functional coaches
get their athletes to bound sprint climb
and battle rape combine this with
compound exercises that build strength
and explosiveness and you get a physique
that is surprisingly shredded sprinting
is fantastic for developing power and
ripped legs crossfit is its own thing
but it follows many of the principles of
functional training and surprise
surprise those athletes have shredded
physiques that would make many
bodybuilders proud and the other big
advantage of functional training when it
comes to aesthetics is that it also
focuses on areas that are often
overlooked
even bodybuilders who are keen to focus
on every muscle group evenly are often
guilty of ignoring the transverse plane
or of not giving enough attention to
their grip take your average bodybuilder
then and get them to start doing
medicine ball throws and rope climbs not
only will this resistance cardio be the
perfect option to cut fat whilst
building muscle but it'll also fill in
all the gaps as it were to develop an
even more rounded physique
functional athletes have highly
developed legs shredded obliques and
serratus muscles thick powerful forearms
add that to a bodybuilder's armor-like
pectorals and massive arms and you have
a superhero-esque physique in the making
so no i don't believe that bodybuilding
and functional training should be in
opposition in fact i think they make
ideal bedfellows and combining these
types of training is surprisingly simple
just perform more functional compound
movements at the start of your workout
transition to isolation movements for
higher repetitions and end with some
conditioning such as sprinting or
spinning a bulgarian bag a ppl split is
also perfectly suited to this approach
meanwhile if you only perform
bodybuilding or only perform functional
training take comfort knowing that
you're developing functional strength
and aesthetics either way
hope you found this video useful
interesting guys let me know what you
think do you think that bodybuilding is
more functional than it looks and do you
think that functional training is a good
way to develop a cool physique if you're
interested in developing a physique that
is both functional and aesthetic then
you might like my ebook and training
program super functional training and
there i also incorporate lots of other
benefits of different kinds of training
including mobility brain function and
much more
alternatively if you just want to learn
about functional training and how it
applies to the general population and
athletes then check out my print book
functional training and beyond please
leave a like and share this video around
it helps me out immensely and subscribe
of course if you want to see more like
this hit the bell button if you want to
be notified of future uploads thank you
so much for watching this one guys and
i'll see you next time
bye for now